bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce dimanche
la tension est toujours là draguignan
autour de la famille du jeune homme tué
hier alors qu'ils tentaient de s'évader
l'auteur des coups de feu un gendarme a
été entendu par un juge aujourd'hui il
devrait être mis en examen dans les
heures qui viennent
le grand format ce soir nous emmènera en
afrique du sud où le pays est confronté
à une vague meurtrière de xénophobie
les victimes sont les immigrants des
pays limitrophes nous irons dans les
townships de johannesburg
le palmarès du festival de cannes 2008
quel sera le choix du jury présidé par
sean penn le cinéma français attend
depuis 21 ans une palme d'or entre les
murs entre fiction et documentaire de
laurent cantet a touché la critique hier
première réaction sur le palmarès à la
fin de cette édition
cap sur l'euro les protégés de raymond
domenech sont à tignes les bleus
lyonnais vainqueur de la coupe de france
vont les rejoindre
ils sont 30 pré sélectionnés ne seront
plus que 23 mercredi
enfin les premières balles et les
premiers résultats à roland garros
nous retrouverons patrice dominguez avec
in feront le point sur les favoris du
tournoi cette année
une page s'est déjà tourné aujourd'hui
avec les adieux du triple vainqueur
brésilien gustavo kuerten
voilà pour les titres de ce dimanche
bienvenue dans cette édition et on
commence ce journal par l'une des images
du jour elle nous vient de lyon où les
supporters ont fêté cet après-midi le
deuxième titre de la saison la coupe de
france que l'ol a remporté hier soir
face au paris saint germain
les joueurs ont été reçus aujourd'hui à
la mairie ça faisait 35 ans mais les
lyonnais n'avaient pas remporté cette
coupe de france
dans l'actualité également les violents
orages qui ont touché la nuit dernière
et cet après midi le sud ouest du pays
de fortes pluies se sont abattues sur
les landes la dordogne mais également
sur la région viticole du madiran dans
les hautes pyrénées ont fait le point ce
soir avec romain mi6 la grêle a laissé
des traces
vingt-quatre heures après l'orage ce
viticulteur ne peut que constater les
dégâts
c'était une vigne qui était quasiment
prête à fleurir
et là vous pourrez constater qu'il n'ya
plus de vignes plus de réserve 10 à 20
centimètres de grêle tombée en quelques
minutes hier soir sur cette petite
commune et qui ont toutes endommagé
vignes champs de maïs et même la toiture
des maisons vous voyez certaines tortues
ont souffert mais je crois que le plus
grave ce sont les cultures et nos sa
mise en production de semences de maïs
donc apparemment tout est détruit
on sait pas on sait pas à ce show on va
on va se rattraper dans la région du
madiran aussi la grêle a fait des dégâts
ici sur 1600 hectares de vignes 40% sont
définitivement détruit une centaine de
producteurs a tout perdu il y aura pas
de récolte en septembre la récolte et la
récolte a disparu elle et les parterres
quoi seul espoir pour ces viticulteurs
que la région soit reconnu comme zone
sinistrée pour que les assurances
remboursent en partie les dégâts le
gendarme qui a abattu un homme vendredi
durant son évasion à draguignan pourrait
être mis en examen pour homicide
volontaire la nuit dernière quatre
véhicules avaient été incendiés dans la
caserne de gendarmerie de brignoles
c'est là-bas que la victime avait été
interpellé aujourd'hui le service
d'information des armées a fait savoir
que les gendarmes ont le droit de faire
usage de leurs armes après sommation
nathalie jourdan jean claude duchesne
les proches de joseph guerdner vient de
voir sa dépouille à la sortie de la
morgue de la colère des malaises et des
larmes
le procureur de la république de
draguignan avait exceptionnellement
autorisé la famille à voir le corps du
défunt avant l'autopsié
une décision d'apaisement dans un climat
très tendu
dès hier soir le préfet du var avaient
fait déployer 150 hommes afin de
protéger les casernes de gendarmerie du
département
nous avons pris des mesures de
précaution nous avons été renforcés par
des éléments de la gendarmerie mobile et
également par des collègues de la police
nationale lire sur au niveau
départemental malgré ces renforts quatre
véhicules ont été incendiés dans la cour
intérieure de la gendarmerie de
brignoles c'est là que joseph guerdner
avait été interpellé avant son transfert
à draguignan depuis le milieu de l'après
midi
le militaire auteur des coups de feu
mortels est entendu par deux magistrats
instructeurs à draguignan le procureur
de la république a ouvert une
information judiciaire
il a également requis un mandat de dépôt
à l'encontre du jean bart un souci
d'apaisement par la nécessité également
de protéger l'intéressé vous savez qu'il
a été victime de deux menace extrêmement
précise et directe mais c'est aussi en
considération d'ordre public
vous savez quand vous êtes du voyage si
vous êtes poursuivi pour avoir volé
quelque chose on est plusieurs mois en
détention provisoire donc là si
aujourd'hui celui qui est présumé avoir
tué l'un des leurs ce n'était pas une
car serré je crois qu'il ne le
comprendrais pas c'est désormais au juge
des libertés de la détention de suivre
ou non l'avis du procureur il rendra sa
décision après la mise en examen du
militaire celle ci doit intervenir dans
la soirée
je vous en parlais hier trois jeunes
issus de régions différentes s'étaient
donné rendez vous jeudi via internet
pour se donner la mort dans une forêt du
nord de la france ce pacte suicidaire a
heureusement échoué
la justice a très vite ordonné la
fermeture du forum de discussion sur
lesquels les trois jeunes s'étaient
rencontrés le suicide même s'il est en
baisse depuis quelques années
représentent la deuxième cause de
mortalité chez les 15 24 ans pierre
monnet gier
david da meda suicide écoute bonjour la
prévention des suicides est une affaire
d'écoutés des bénévoles formés à épauler
les personnes en souffrance
il est quand même suivi par quelqu un
médecin libérer la parole et aux besoins
orienté vers un professionnel
au bout du fil des adultes des personnes
âgées peu de jeunes
les jeunes aujourd'hui se confie
d'ailleurs le plus souvent sur des
forums internet
ça leur permet de former peut-être un
petit groupe imaginant peut-être que ça
pourrait les aider à sortir de là
situation et le côté pervers de la chose
c'est que souvent ils se rencontrent et
fomentent ensemble un projet qui peut
aboutir à une catastrophe
c'est ce qui s'est passé jeudi dans le
nord de la france dans cette forêt des
jeunes ont tenté de mettre fin à leurs
jours
ils ne se connaissaient pas venez de
régions différentes mais s'étaient
rencontrés sur ce forum de discussion à
la rubrique suicide 675 message des mots
pour dire son mal-être d'autres beaucoup
plus explicite pour passer à l'acte
l'ordinateur comme confident
d'adolescents à problèmes un maire ne
comprends pas j'ai essayé d'en parler
autour de moi mes amis en ont marre de
voir si triste et finalement la dose
s'adresse à un interlocuteur virtuel qui
est accessible écrit très disponible il
y a deux ans deux adolescentes s'était
jeté d'une falaise après avoir annoncé
leur suicide sur leur blog
mais le phénomène reste marginal comparé
au nombre de suicide des jeunes chaque
année douze mille d'entre tente de
mettre fin à leurs jours et six ans y
parviennent les pêcheurs restent divisés
quant à la reprise du travail certains
ont déjà décidé de repartir en mer par
exemple à saint gilles croix de vie en
vendée nombreuses assemblées générales
sont prévues demain matin et c'est
désormais l'approvisionnement en
poissons qui pose problème pas de pêche
des camions stopper et c'est toute la
filière qui se retrouvent bloqués
parfois exemple à l'île de ré et à la
rochelle ce matin ann guy ep bernard
connor seulement quelques kilos de bulot
ce poissonnier de l'île de ré est venu
au marché la mort dans l'âme depuis dix
jours il n'a aucune marchandise à
proposer
normalement le marché il est plein on
on est deux poissonniers qu'il ya du
monde partout dans les allées voilà
voilà
il y à bien les fleurs pour la fête des
mères mais à marcher sans poisson se
vide de ses clients dans les possibles
marché ce match s'il manque quelque peu
de commerçants on est pénalisé se ranger
sur la viande
bref à des grillades seulement une somme
je me crois par rapport aux problèmes de
vue pour une bonne cause sur le quai des
mareyeurs à la rochelle aucun camion
le port est toujours bloquée par les
pêcheurs pour frédéric magne qui s'est
installé il ya trois mois cet art est
une catastrophe
mais voilà sur les classes vides et ça
fait dix jours que ça dure
je pense que si les frigos reste vide
ses huit salariés seront au chômage
technique
les mareyeurs espère des aides publiques
pour les charges et les loyers
aujourd'hui encore les bateaux pêchent
sont restés à quai
ce sont 2000 personnes qui se retrouvent
sans activité mais ce soir le ministre
de la pêche michel barnier appelle tous
les pêcheurs à reprendre le travail à
l'étranger tout d'abord la chine
avec cette nouvelle réplique qui a
frappé la province du sichuan est la
plus forte depuis la catastrophe douze
mais elle a entraîné selon les autorités
l'effondrement de 70 mille habitations
on craint toujours que ces répliques ne
fragilise une nouvelle fois les
importants barrages situés dans la
région
il y a trois semaines le liban souvenez
vous connaissez un vrai regain de
violence on craignait à nouveau une
guerre civile
et voilà qu'aujourd'hui le pays semble
retrouver une forme de stabilité certes
précaire mais avec à sa tête enfin un
nouveau président il s'agit du général
michel sleiman il va avoir la lourde
tâche de réconcilier le pays si
jean-marc il use et kalachnikov au
vestiaire et des députés votant dans le
calme pour donner enfin un président un
liban qui vient tout juste de frôler une
nouvelle guerre civile
voilà de quoi rassurer les 5 millions de
libanais qui attendait depuis six mois
que pro et anti syrien elise
effectivement cet homme michel sleiman
59 ans chrétien maronite comme l'exigé
la constitution patron de l'armée un
homme suffisamment neutre ou fat selon
les points de vue pour avoir le soutien
de tous la paix civile est à ce prix le
plus important c'est que les libanais de
toutes les communautés recommence à
vivre ensemble à travailler ensemble à
espérer ensemble
le président sleiman a bien sûr lancé un
appel à l'unité nationale mais en
insistant sur l'importance des liens
avec le voisin syrien et la protection
des frontières face à israël grosse
satisfaction des représentants de l'iran
et de la syrie
puissant allié des milices chiites du
hezbollah a bola plus gourmand que
jamais après avoir fait la preuve de sa
forme au début du mois il a fini par
obtenir une minorité de blocage au
parlement
autant dire que si l'élection du
président slimane rime avec
normalisation il lui restera beaucoup à
faire pour qu'elle devienne véritable
réconciliation manuel marulanda était le
chef historique des farc
les autorités colombiennes avaient tiers
annoncé sa mort la guérilla l'a confirmé
aujourd'hui
reste maintenant à savoir si cette
information qui affaiblit une nouvelle
fois la guérilla aura une influence ou
non sur l'avenir des otages et notamment
sur lui d'ingrid betancourt pour ses
proches
c'est en tout cas un nouvel espoir
question hautain et philippe peyroux
c'est officiel après 40 années de lutte
armée manuel marulanda le chef
historique des farc est mort une
information confirmée par la guérilla
elle mermoz nous vous informons que m
commandant en chef manuel manuel
marulanda est mort le 26 mars d'une
crise cardiaque
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour la
rébellion colombienne qui a aussitôt
annoncé la nomination d'un nouveau
leader alfonso cano fondateur des farc
en 1964 manuel marulanda avait constitué
au fil des ans une armée de 17 mille
combattants financé par le trafic de
cocaïne et la prise d'otages et depuis
l'élection d'alvaro uribe en 2002 les
guérilleros ont subi deux cuisants
revers
raul reyes le numéro deux du mouvement a
été tué le 1er mars dernier et les
désertions se sont multipliés le
président uribe affirme que les rebelles
seraient maintenant prêts à libérer des
otages le gouvernement a reçu des appels
des farc dans lesquelles certains
dirigeants ont annoncé leur intention de
se démobiliser et de libérer les otages
dont ingrid betancourt difficile pour
autant de prévoir les conséquences de la
mort de marulanda pour les dizaines
d'otages dont ingrid betancourt sa
famille prudente se veut optimiste
tout ce qui s'est passé au cours des
deux derniers mois avec les différentes
mort les différentes désertion qui ont
existé au rang des farc
on se dit qu'il ya des bouleversements
essentiel en ce moment et il faut que
ces gouvernements puissent permettre de
trouver des solutions qui permettront la
libération des otages et bernard
kouchner le ministre des affaires
étrangères redoutent un assaut de
l'armée colombienne contre la rébellion
a faibli même privée de son leader
historique la guérilla marxiste et ses
9000 combattants contrôlent encore de
larges portions du territoire colombien
et ce soir le président nicolas sarkozy
a déclaré que face à une grave crise de
violence xénophobe
euh non ceux sur le président sarkozy a
déclaré que des choses se passent en
colombie à propos des otages mais qu'il
faut évidemment faire preuve je cite de
beaucoup de prudence
je vous le disais en triste l'afrique du
sud doit faire face à une grave crise de
violence xénophobe le président mbeki
est extrêmement critiqué pour son
inaction
lyon depuis quinze jours dans les
quartiers les plus pauvres dans les
townships ce le conte croyait être des
amis sont devenus des ennemis
les personnes ciblées viennent des pays
limitrophes le premier bilan fait état
déjà de 50 morts et trente cinq mille
déplacés nos équipes ont pu se rendre à
johannesburg
dans l'un de ces quartiers c'est le
grand format de ce soir il est signé
dominique derda et frédéric ranque
ici au moins ils n'ont plus rien à
craindre entre le temple méthodiste et
le commissariat de police de primrose
dans la banlieue ouest de johannesbourg
ils sont un peu plus de deux mille à
avoir trouvé refuge un repas chaud un
peu de chaleur humaine
quand on a tout perdu c'est déjà pas si
mal l'afrique du sud il était venu
chercher une vie meilleure ce soir
demain ou dans quelques jours tous
repartiront dans leur pays natal au
zimbabwe et au mozambique au malawi plus
question pour eux de rester rice
j'habite ici depuis 1995 chaque jour je
mangeais avec mes voisins ont été
annulés et puis un soir il indigné en
plus de vous les étrangers dehors you
want to go balle est rentrée chez vous
oui parce que sinon on va mourir ici
d'un à deux kilomètres à peine les
premières maisons brûlées c'est dans ce
bidonville que vivaient les étrangers le
pré montez pénètre et costaud et sud
africain il appartient à une petite
ethnie minoritaire
il n'a pas participé aux violences dit
il en revanche il a tout ils ont versé
de l'essence sur la maison et puis ils
ont jeter une allumette et voilà et il
ya eu des morts oui
six personnes sont mortes et six
personne évidemment ne reconnaît avoir
mis le feu et moins encore avoir tué qui
que ce soit mais il serait bien
difficile de trouver parmi ces zulo qui
compte pour regretter le départ
précipité des immigrés bien au contraire
il y a quinze ans qu'on vit en
démocratie et on est toujours aussi
pauvre une kia travail rien même le pain
est trop cher c'est tout vous comprenez
où c'est celui fait c'est de la faute
des étrangers
oui et pour ça il faut les tuer non on
ne l'est qu'à paris on les chasse c'est
tout les pauvres contre les pauvres et
au milieu la police l'armée sud
africaine envoyée en renfort
toujours incapable de mettre un terme à
ces agressions meurtrières en deux
semaines une cinquantaine de morts
plusieurs centaines de blessés
entre trente et quarante mille réfugiés
et ce n'est pas fini on en a plus
qu'assez de ces étrangers ils doivent
retourner dans leur pays
ici c'est la tribu du sud pour la
première fois une manifestation contre
la xénophobie organisée par les églises
et des mouvements pacifistes a réuni
plusieurs milliers de personnes dans les
rues de johannesburg
les avec un taux de chômage de 30 à 40%
avec une criminalité qui frappe plus
durement encore les misérables que la
nouvelle bourgeoisie noire
il faudra l'afrique du sud bien plus que
les prières et de généraux discours pour
surmonter cette crise aux etats-unis la
crise qui touche les crédits immobiliers
ne cesse de pousser de plus en plus
d'américains à quitter leurs maisons
obligé de vendre les remboursements
devenant impossible
une situation qui pousse certains vous
allez le voir à détruire a saccagé une
partie de leurs biens avant de rendre
les clés reportage alain de chalvron et
ariel monange pendant la campagne
électorale les expulsions continuent
occultée par le débat politique
elle redouble même alors que la crise du
crédit immobilier touche de plus en plus
de monde à l'américaine sans sentiments
les déménageurs arrive mettre les
meubles sur le trottoir et les expulser
n'ont plus que leurs yeux pour pleurer
quand j'ai appelé la société de crédit
ils m'ont juste dit bon si vous ne
pouvez plus payer quitter la maison et
laissez-nous les clés seulement
maintenant souffler un vent de révolte
de plus en plus de gens rendent leur
maison méticuleusement vandalisé
destruction systématique des murs des
toilettes des installations électriques
des décorations
on casse la rage au coeur dans un esprit
de vengeance
on a trouvé des toilettes détruite à
coups de masse on a vu des gens qui
avaient éventré les tuyauteries pour
laisser l'eau s'échappe et couper les
conduits d'air conditionné ont arraché
les câbles électriques et c'est efficace
ses propriétés vandalisé deviennent
invendables même à prix bradés jusqu'à
50%
quand je suis rentré dans la maison ça
sentait trop mauvais jeu tourné les
talons
de toute manière je ne voulais pas d'une
maison qui plus est comme ça résultat
les banques qui récupère ainsi des
maisons saccagées doivent investir des
sommes importantes pour les restaurer
perte d'argent perte de temps d'où
l'idée d'une prime au bon état propose
une incitation financière pour que les
gens laissent la maison en bon état
c'est-à-dire qu'ils prennent leurs
affaires et qu'il s'en aille mais ça
peut aller de quelques centaines de
dollars amis et plus
mais à aucun moment il ne viendrait à
l'idée de quiconque que le plus simple
serait peut-être éviter les saisies en
renégociant par exemple les crédits
alors renault a négocié les crédits
n'est pas d'actualité avec mme alain de
chalvron bonsoir bonsoir alain deux
petites questions ce soir ce n'est pas
la première fois que l'on parle de ces
américains qui doivent vendre tout
d'abord qui sont les victimes et qui
sont les responsables de cette situation
ont écouté c'est le résultat d'une
double inconscience des emprunteurs et
des prêteurs les prêteurs les sociétés
de crédit pas très reluisante souvent on
pousser les gens au crime tout
simplement en les ont poussés à
s'endetter encore et encore alors qu'il
n'en avait pas les moyens on pouvait
acheter une voire deux maisons sans la
moindre mise de départ
quant aux emprunteurs ils sont laissé
prendre dans ce tourbillon et ont
surtout éviter de négliger négliger je
veux dire de regarder vous savez les
clauses écrit en tout petit car la
plupart de ces crédits étaient
renégociable passant de 5 6% à 17 18 au
bout de trois quatre cinq ans alors tant
que le marché flambé de 15% à 20% par an
en moyenne
il y avait pas de problème les prêteurs
et est toujours assurée de récupérer
leurs fonds et les emprunteurs pouvait
toujours vendre leur maison avec
bénéfices au moment de la renégociation
du crédit et racheter notre maison mais
quand les prix ont commencé à
s'effondrer
patatras on estime que cette année deux
millions de maisons vont être ainsi
saisi ça veut dire deux millions de
familles essentiellement classes
moyennes inférieures qui vont se
retrouver sur le trottoir merci alain
autre image du jour elle nous vient de
l'aéroport de bruxelles où un avion
cargo un boeing 747 s'est littéralement
brisé en deux lors de son décollage
il n'y avait à bord que les cinq membres
d'équipage aucun n'a été blessé mais
l'un d'eux est tout de même en état de
choc est maintenant déterminer la raison
de ce crash
le 25 mai pour les parents d'enfants
disparus devenu une date symbolique
chaque année et ce retour au champ de
mars à paris pour rendre tout simplement
mal
l'enfant l'an dernier en france 540 deux
mineurs ont disparu de manière
inquiétante ou inexpliqués et c'est
demain que souvent belgique le procès
d'une affaire qui avait fortement ému le
pays quelque temps après l affaire
dutroux
deux petites filles de 7 et 10 ans avait
alors disparu en juin 2006 avant d'être
retrouvé trois semaines plus tard morte
à liège un homme de main sera dans le
box des accusés
retour sur une affaire qui a traumatisé
toute une région
aurélia guillemin et jean-marie le
quartier dans le petit square
les enfants ont recommencé à jouer les
habitants de ce quartier populaire de
liège ont appris à vivre avec le drame
sur les lieux du souvenir
le temps a terni les petites peluches
déposés ici en hommage mais n'a rien
effacé du traumatisme de ceux qui vivent
la loi chère de poing colo c'est qu'on
les a trouvés là c'est quelque chose qui
qui respirait sera revu jusqu'à temps
qu'on ait envie est ça l est
les petites nathalie un jean et stacy
sept ans disparaissent le 10 juin 2006
encore sous le choc de la sphère du trou
la belgique est rattrapé par ses vieux
démons et mis tout en oeuvre pour les
retrouver vivantes
c'est une course contamment en france il
s'est plié deux sont en vie ça que
j'espère beaucoup c'est une course
contre la montre
mais après trois semaines de recherches
la police découvre deux cadavres
les fillettes ont été étranglées la plus
grande violée la dernière fois qu'on les
a vus
elle jouait ensemble tout près de ce bar
ce jour là c'est la braderie du quartier
il est tard mais tout le monde s'amuse
les fillettes sont enlevés sans un bruit
sans un cri sans témoin la maman de
nathalie était là mais elle non plus n'a
rien vu je serai toujours rangés par
papin projet
sent toujours responsable d'un manque de
surveillance à l'ap de temps mais ça je
l'aimerai toujours pas accès abdallah
ait oud est rapidement arrêté ce soir là
il a abordé plusieurs jeunes filles et
des enfants à qui il a proposé d'aller
chercher des tortues dans la forêt pas
de traces adn pour le confondre
mais des fibres textiles retrouvées sur
ses vêtements trouve qu'il a été en
contact direct avec les deux fillettes
lui n'a jamais reconnu les faits
abdallah est ce que vous êtes récents
multi récidiviste abdallah ait oud a
déjà été condamné deux fois pour viols
sur mineure lors de la précédente
affaire il est jugé irresponsable et
internés dans cet hôpital psychiatrique
dont il sort au bout de quatre ans
un psychiatre a estimé qu'il n'était pas
fou et qu'il aurait dû être jugé ou pas
on se trompe et d'orientation la porte
est ouverte
parce qu'on en fait c'est exactement ça
ils pensent aussi simplement dramatique
absurdité de la loi belge de l'époque
ait woods n'a plus sa place en
psychiatrie mais ne peux plus retourner
en prison
il est donc libéré sans le moindre soin
sur la vie d'un seul expert il a lâché
dans la nature une grenade dégoupillée
c'est ma vie et sa copine qui ont sauté
dessus
je trouve que c'est tout aussi criminel
est donc quelque part je pose la
question est-ce qu'il dort bien
vos non non
non ce fait deux ans je ne dors pas mes
deux ans que ce père de famille étudie
méticuleusement le dossier il veut
pouvoir affronter le procès maîtres
comme il dit un visage sur ces
cauchemars notre rubrique mai 68 touche
à sa fin avec un retour ce soir sur les
grandes grèves et ses hommes qui ont
vécu ce mouvement social d'anciens
grévistes qui sont revenus dans l'un des
hauts lieux de cette lutte la gare saint
lazare à paris daniel wolfromm bruno
girodon des souvenirs de grève préservé
comme dans un album de famille difficile
de remonter le temps il y à 40 en mai 68
la grève générale la gare saint-lazare
vide et un silence de cathédrale
on entendait l'horloge le petit pack de
leurs laquais
on l'entendait c'est la première fois
qu'on entendait se
les dépôts de la sncf débrayent un art
on arrête le travail comme dans le reste
du pays où les usines et les entreprises
ferment plus personne ne circule
et comme en 1936 on occupe les lieux
je suis pourquoi pourquoi parce qu'on
était très peu début de la grève
on se trouvait à 42 40 de grévistes
après que la gare c'est venu après petit
à petit petit à petit jusqu'à former un
chiffre inouï non égalée depuis le 24
mai 1968 on atteint les 10 millions de
grévistes
c'était une partie de rigolade à paris
les cheminots de saint lazare
s'installent dans leur grève
ils vont tenir trois semaines il grâce
au soutien de quelques artistes vedettes
de l'époque qui eu disons à l'entrée une
ovation terrible il ya on renoue avec
les grèves légal de 36 on a dansé on a
chanté et comment 36 la même hantise
l'incursion dans la gare de groupes de
tous bords venus de l'extérieur c'est
contre l'extrême droite ça oui oui
oui et puis aussi
les grossistes mais entre-temps patronat
et syndicats signent les accords de
grenelle le smig augmente de 30% pour
les cheminots de saint lazare c'est une
belle victoire
on a eu de très bonnes avancées de par
exemple les congés sont passés de 26
jours à 28 jours les augmentations de
salaire de 10 à 16%
on reconnaît plus rien c'est terminé il
y avait des superbes grille plus de
grille mais une cour de gare transformée
en oeuvre d'un avec sa statue faite
d'horloge comme pour retrouver un passé
mais 68 il y à 40 ans déjà beaucoup de
sport ce week-end avec tout d'abord le
premier jour de roland garros avec déjà
des adieux ceux du brésilien gustavo
kuerten qui avait remporté à trois
reprises l'open paris il est tombé face
au français paul henri mathieu reportage
nathanaël de rincquesen et bruno vignais
aujourd'hui il régnait comme un air de
samba cet après midi à roland garros
des spécialistes appellent ça les fait
kuerten du nom de ce champion brésilien
vainqueur du tournoi à trois reprises et
qu'ils refassent par farines dernière
fois avant de quitter le tennis
kuerten
c'est l'honneur du brésil vous comprenez
on l'aiment tout à l'heure avant de
rentrer sur le central gustavo kuerten
est allé s'échauffer sur un petit court
du stade pour le plus grand bonheur des
supporteurs français
ravi de le voir jouer est ravi de
pouvoir l'approcher autographes sourire
kuerten ne refuse jamais rien à son
public qu'est ce que vous pensez du
public français merveilleux
pour moi c'est toujours un grand plaisir
de me retrouver ici ça va me manquer de
ne plus venir
il attendait malheureusement pour lui
paul henri mathieu son adversaire du
jour affiche une forme éblouissante et
une santé éclatante avec sa hanche
récalcitrante et ses 31 ans
guga montre au public il a encore de
très beaux restes
mais certainement pas assez pour
inquiéter le 19e joueur mondial
toujours plein d'humour le brésilien a
bien tenté d'étrangler le français mais
après trois sets
kuerten s'incline logiquement onze ans
après son premier titre le brésilien
quitte roland garros en larmes et en
français et moi c'est moi vivre -
impatients - amour roland garros après
l'ovation du public
kuerten reçoit les félicitations des
joueurs qui l'attendait dans les
vestiaires du central pour la dernière
fois alors qualifications aujourd'hui de
djokovic de nalbandian chez les hommes
et chez les femmes d'ivanovic et on va
prendre tout de suite la direction de la
porte de saint-cloud à paris on retrouve
notre consultant patrice dominguez
bonsoir patrice alors c'est parti pour
la quinzaine
on connaît les favoris nadal federer
quels sont les autres siders chez les
hommes et chez les femmes il y en a deux
de plus chez les hommes c'est ce qui
faisait partie avec nadal et federer
l'année dernière du dernier carré en
l'occurrence le serbe djokovic qui a
gagné aujourd'hui
et puis le russe nikolay davydenko tous
les quatre c'est à dire les quatre
meilleurs joueurs du monde étaient en
demi finale l'année dernière
mais roland garros est un tournoi sur
quinze jours avec beaucoup d'efforts à
fournir il ya toujours quelques
surprises
il ya l'argentin david nalbandian et
puis on l'espère toujours il y aura
peut-être un français qui créera un
exploit et qui se hissera jusqu'à la
deuxième semaine
alors justement un mot des français
tsonga blessé gasquet fragile depuis le
début de la saison et puis amélie
mauresmo diminuer ses attention danger
plutôt un ya du danger pour les français
les français ce soir on a eu une belle
satisfaction avec la qualification
d'alizé cornet qui représente l'une des
plus belles chances amélie mauresmo
jouera demain finalement elle vient dans
un nouvel état d'esprit parce qu' elle
n'est plus dans une position de favorite
elle n'a plus à prouver qu'elle est la
meilleure joueuse du monde
ici elle a connu pas mal de galères
depuis un an et demi donc elle va je
l'espère entrée sur le court davantage
libéré et j'espère surtout que le public
ne viendra pas pour la juger comme les
années précédentes mais pour la soutenir
sa carrière le mérite je pense que
l'exemple de google devrait inspirer le
public de demain
et puis il ya marion bartoli y en a
d'autres qui peuvent s'illustrer
aller jusqu'en deuxième semaine
également merci patrice et bonne
quinzaine le championnat de ligue 1
terminé la coupe de france plier les
lyonnais sélectionnés viennent de
rejoindre les bleus en stage à tignes
car la saison de football n'est pas
terminée objectif l'euro maintenant qui
commencera le 7 juin en suisse et en
autriche reportage sur place à tignes
manuel tissier andré germain l'air pur
de la montagne est un compagnon fidèle
des footballeurs français
chaque compétition majeure attire depuis
dix ans d'épisodes de spectateurs dans
une station ouverte exclusivement aux
bleus et à leurs suiveurs un moment de
détente et de partage avant le début des
hostilités
ça me fait un peu drôle de les voir
comme ça cette année
une menace plane pourtant au dessus du
glacier dans trois jours raymond
domenech doit annoncer à sept joueurs
qui ne poursuivront pas l'aventuré de
l'euro une perspective qui va pas l'air
de gâter l'ambiance on n'y pense même
pas parce qu'on est arrivés on a
commencé à chambrer il ya une bonne
atmosphère donc c'est je pense que ça
sera la veille ou
domenech va annoncer annoncé ça que pet
que là il y aura un peu plus de pression
le sélectionneur français et surtout
roger lemerre ont toujours été
accueillis comme des princes en haute
tarentaise
c'est aimé jacquet en 97 qui avait lancé
ses stages conviviaux et ludique
à l'époque les bleus étaient plus
accessibles les en 2006 domenech a
choisi de souder son équipe sur le
glacier loin des caméras
et cette année les familles n'ont pas
été conviés car le sélectionneur va
annoncer à sept joueurs ou mauvaise
nouvelle
ça sera un peu comme un accident de la
circulation
arrivera là ce soir avec l'arrivée des
lyonnais le groupe sera au complet
bien sûr les 30 joueurs ne partent pas
sur la même ligne sous la pluie de
tignes ils peuvent encore tous espéré un
seul homme a les clés de leur avenir
une image enfin du grand prix de monaco
à un grand prix émaillée par de nouveaux
accidents spectaculaires mais la
victoire est revenue au britannique
lewis hamilton sur mclaren mercedes il
reprend grâce à cette victoire la
première place au classement des pilotes
à kimi räikkönen qui s'est classé
neuvième seulement aujourd'hui et on
reste sur la côte d'azur pour à la can
pour découvrir le palmarès du festival
qui a remporté la palme et bien c'est le
film entre les murs film français de
laurent cantet cela faisait 21 ans que
le cinéma français n'avait pas reçu ce
prix avant de retrouver toute l'équipe
du film on fait tout de suite le premier
bilan avec emmanuel lambert et guillaume
michel énorme surprise du chahut au
festival de cannes forcément laurent
quand tu es toute sa classe de quatrième
sont là le réalisateur français reçoit
la palme d'or pour entre les murs un
film exceptionnel selon sean penn
mes autres récompenses elle était
attendue prix d'interprétation masculine
pour l'acteur benicio del toro c'est lui
qui incarne l'ofce avec brio les frères
dardenne toujours gâtés à cannes
deux fois palme d'or ils se sont vu
décerner le prix du meilleur scénario
pour le silence de lorna la france
encore à l'honneur catherine deneuve
reçoit un prix spécial pour son rôle
dans le film un conte de noël et pour
l'ensemble de sa carrière
si heureuse de pouvoir faire encore
aujourd'hui des films comme celui là
avec tant d'énergie d'intelligence de
sensibilité une palme d'or française
plus de 20 ans que l'on attendait ça
élégance et diversité le festival de
cannes a tenu toutes ses promesses c'est
désormais le clap de fin mais pas pour
le septième art qui lui est éternel
voilà les choses se sont donc précipités
à cames avec nous ce soir toute l'équipe
d'entre les murs le film palme d'or de
laurent cantet il s'appelle juliette
esmeralda souleymane ce sont les élèves
du collège françoise dolto situé dans le
xxème arrondissement de paris qui
incarnent les personnages de ce film
donc primé ce soir bonsoir à tous la
première question est à vous le rend
compte et c'était déjà du bonheur d'être
à cannes alors quel est le sentiment qui
vous traverse depuis on va dire quelques
minutes
bah oui effectivement c'était déjà du
bonheur d'être ici
pour le moment je suis encore un petit
peu sur un nuage j'ai pas encore tout à
fait réalisé chèque le
le bonheur aussi c'est de le partager
avec avec tout le monde ici et je pense
que dans un petit moment on comprendra
mieux ce qui nous arrive mais non je
suis très très heureux alors juste pour
les téléspectateurs comment vous
définiriez votre film c'est un film à la
fois un peu documentaire tout de même
c'est vrai que c'est un film documente
et qui avons un film qui raconte une
histoire qui est une vraie fiction mais
cette fiction et se situe dans un dans
le cadre de l'école et essaye de
restituer une réalité
très très compliqué que quelques quelle
école un film inspiré d'un livre de
françois bégaudeau qui est à côté de
vous je crois et qui joue son propre
rôle quel est votre émotion ce soir
françois bégaudeau je suis évidemment
ému et content surtout content pour pour
les 25 loulou qui sont derrière moi et
puis pour laurent parce que non
seulement c'est un grand cinéaste mais
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui est comment
dire très humain et qui est très
agréable à fréquenter donc vraiment ça
fait plaisir le dernier français qui a
eu la pince et pialat et je crois que si
tu es un peu en cette famille-là toutes
proportions gardées donc vraiment où
tout est formidable dans cette affaire
alors comment avez vous sélectionné ces
enfants qui vous entoure et j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir les entendre
en fait c'est eux qui sont choisis on a
animé pendant un moment un atelier
d'improvisation au collège françoise
dolto à paris et puis sont venus
volontairement s'amuser j'espère pendant
quelques heures tous les mercredis
après-midi un certain nombre sont restés
jusqu'au bout et en fait ils sont restés
et si longtemps qu'ils sont derrière moi
aujourd'hui
alors justement je vais en entendre
ainsi nous entende c'est pour vous une
aventure formidable j'imaginais ce que
certains rêvent maintenant d'une
carrière plus longue au cinéma qui va
répondre oui
en fait ouais ça ça pourrait marcher
mais moi je moi j'ai déjà été repérés
ici par la maman de louise que je
remercie et si ça peut continuer
pourquoi pas sa faute une vocation
alors est-ce qu'il a été dur avec vous
le rencontrez pas trop stressé sur le
tournage non alors quelques répond non
non je ne peux être le petit journal
alors une petite rupture de faisceau
apparemment on ne voit plus on retrouve
peu à cannes on va voilà en tout cas
merci à vous tous et puis je souligne
bien évidemment qu'on est très heureux à
france 2 parce que ce film
la palme d'or ce soir est un film
produit par france 2 mais il faudra
attendre le 15 octobre je crois pour
voir le film puisqu'il sortira à ce
moment là sur les écrans voilà pour
l'essentiel de l'information de cette
fin de week-end merci à vous d'avoir
suivi ce journal la météo c'est avec
isabelle martinez puis 20h55 du cinéma
avec le petit lieutenant et nathalie
baye demain l'information à 13h07 avec
olivier galzi 20h david pujadas vous
c'est une très belle soirée et puis on
se quitte sur un extrait justement de ce
film primé ce soir entre les murs prime
le film effectivement palme d'or au
festival de cannes un film france 2
voilà
pas du tout